This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you have even a passing familiarity with Los Angeles, you've probably heard this before. In LA, nobody walks. LA is a city of drivers, a place that feels purpose-built for cars, and to fit all those cars you need a lot of parking. It's one of the a lot of parking. It's one of the greatest concentrations of parking in the world.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你对洛杉矶哪怕只有一丝一毫的了解，你可能以前就听过这种说法。在洛杉矶，没有人走路。洛杉矶是一座驾驶者的城市，一个仿佛专门为汽车建造的地方，为了容纳所有这些汽车，你需要大量的停车场。它是世界上停车位最集中的地方之一。
That's Henry Grabar, author of a new book called Paved Paradise, How Parking Explanions the World. I think in LA, parking has a special place in the mind because we think of LA as a sort of an iconic place to drive with its famous freeways and its palm line boulevards and all that. So I think it's a place where perhaps you get the highest level of contrast between the kind of utopian idea of driving and the dirty reality that is looking for a parking spot. In LA, that dirty reality plays out all the time on the local news. This are flying in a South LA parking lot and an apparent argument overrun parking space. The more spectacular ones tend to make the news
那是亨利·格拉巴尔，新书《铺就的天堂：停车如何解释世界》的作者。我认为在洛杉矶，停车在人们心中占据着特殊的位置，因为我们认为洛杉矶是一个标志性的驾驶胜地，有着著名的公路和棕榈树成荫的大道等等。所以我认为，在这个地方，你或许能体验到驾驶的乌托邦式构想与寻找停车位的残酷现实之间最强烈的反差。在洛杉矶，这种残酷的现实一直在当地的新闻中上演。这些画面拍摄于南洛杉矶的一个停车场，起因似乎是一场关于停车位的争夺。那些更耸人听闻的往往会登上新闻。
if there's a video and you know, two guys fighting with baseball bats and somebody runs the car into a storefront. Like that's gonna make the news, but I think a lot of run of the mill parking fides don't. America has as many as eight parking spaces for every car, but despite all of this abundance, we are constantly fighting with each other about parking. And most of that fighting happens in rec center basements and city council chambers.
如果有视频显示两个家伙拿着棒球棍打架，或者有人把车开进了店面。那就会上新闻，但我认为很多司空见惯的停车纠纷却没有。美国每辆车有多达八个停车位，但尽管有这么多的停车位，我们却一直在为停车位争吵不休。而大部分争吵都发生在活动中心的地下室和市议会大厅里。
You see people fighting over parking in that context, in, for example, community meetings, discussions about zoning, about parking requirements, about what gets built in their neighborhood, because everybody is afraid of new residents encroaching on the parking stock. And that is a kind of parking fight as well, and perhaps one that has more systemic consequences than two guys going at it with baseball bats. LA might be the most extreme parking city on the planet. Parking regulations have made it nearly impossible to build new affordable housing or to renovate old buildings.
你会看到人们在这种情况下为停车争吵，例如在社区会议、关于分区、关于停车要求、关于社区建设的讨论中，因为每个人都害怕新居民侵占停车资源。这也是一种停车争执，而且可能比两个拿着棒球棍的家伙大打出手具有更深远的系统性后果。洛杉矶可能是地球上极端停车城市。停车法规使得建设新的可负担住房或翻新旧建筑变得几乎不可能。
And parking has a massive impact on how the city looks. LA is chock full of commercial strip malls, where buildings sit alone and isolated in a sea of asphalt. And all of this is the result of one policy decision, a policy that has reshaped American cities for the last 80 years. In the early 20th century, LA saw an influx of new residents, something the city wasn't prepared for. Well, especially in the 1920s, you know, the population of the city more than doubled in that decade,
而且停车对城市的外观产生了巨大的影响。洛杉矶到处都是商业 strip mall（露天购物中心），那里的建筑孤零零地矗立在沥青的海洋中。所有这一切都是一项政策决定的结果，这项政策在过去 80 年里重塑了美国城市。在 20 世纪初，洛杉矶迎来了大量新居民，这是这座城市没有准备好的。嗯，特别是在 20 世纪 20 年代，你知道，在这十年里，这座城市的人口增加了一倍多。
you had the most houses built of any time in LA's history. And you also had a massive growth in car ownership. Southern California was the first place in the world with mass ownership of cars. That's Mark Valleon-Auto's. He works for the county public transit agency, but he's also an expert on LA's car culture. I'm a rare parking weirdo, so I'm happy to talk about it.
洛杉矶历史上建造房屋最多的时期就是那个时候。汽车保有量也迎来了爆炸式增长。南加州是世界上最早实现汽车大规模拥有的地方。那是马克·瓦利奥纳托斯的观点。他在县公共交通机构工作，但他也是洛杉矶汽车文化的专家。我是一个罕见的停车怪咖，所以我很乐意谈论这个。
In the early 20th century, Los Angeles had the biggest public transit system in the world by mileage. Their streetcars and trolleys were well-loved, but thanks to mismanagement and a cultural shift towards driving and possibly a massive conspiracy by car companies, LA let its trains fall into disrepair, and they made a choice to become a city of motorists. By 1920, you had one car per household, essentially. It was like 10 to 12 times as many as in Chicago at that time. And so therefore, you also had a whole bunch of people figuring out how humans could live with cars in a city, right?
在 20 世纪初，洛杉矶拥有按里程计算世界上最大公共交通系统。他们的有轨电车广受欢迎，但由于管理不善、驾驶文化转变，以及可能存在的汽车公司的巨大阴谋，洛杉矶任由其列车失修，他们做出了成为汽车城市的选择。到 1920 年，基本上每户拥有一辆车。这大约是当时芝加哥的 10 到 12 倍。因此，你也会看到一大群人摸索着人类如何在城市里与汽车共存，对吧？
Garages and car ports and just figuring out where to put the cars. The shift to becoming a car culture required a lot of changes to the urban landscape. California had to build highways to accommodate all this driving. Most parking in LA at the time was curbside, and as the population boomed, street parking became a rare commodity, which inspired panic at City Hall. There was an annual report of the Board of LA City Planning Commissioners that talked about what they'd done the past year, their goals for the next year. And there's a picture of a sort of empty street
车库、车棚，以及弄清楚把车停在哪里。转向汽车文化需要对城市景观进行大量改造。加州不得不修建高速公路来适应所有这些驾驶需求。当时洛杉矶的大部分停车位都是路边停车，随着人口激增，街边停车位成了稀缺商品，这引发了市政厅的恐慌。洛杉矶市规划委员会董事会有一份年度报告，讨论了他们过去一年所做的事情以及对下一年的目标。其中有一张照片，展示了一条刚刚开发 空旷街道。
that's just getting developed. There's one apartment building on it. And it's like a four-story masonry apartment building. Parked in front of it, we're about maybe 15 to 20 cars. City planners worried about the consequences if every new apartment building needed 15 to 20 curbside parking spaces. In 1931, LA introduced a policy that changed how urban planning works in the United States.
上面有一栋公寓楼。那是一栋四层的砖石公寓楼。停在它前面的大约有 15 到 20 辆车。城市规划者担心，如果每栋新公寓楼都需要 15 到 20 个路边停车位，会产生什么后果。1931 年，洛杉矶出台了一项改变美国城市规划运作方式的政策。
They made a law requiring parking minimums for new residential buildings. For any new apartment with 20 or more units, there had to be one covered parking spot per unit. Here's Henry Grubar. These parking minimum laws would become virtually ubiquitous in the United States in the second half of the 20th century. But in LA at this time, I think you can understand the logic because they're sitting there and
他们通过了一项法律，要求新建住宅建筑必须满足最低停车位标准。对于任何拥有 20 个或更多单元的新公寓，每个单元必须配有一个有盖停车位。这位是亨利·格拉巴尔。这些最低停车位法律在 20 世纪下半叶成为美国实际上普遍存在的规定。但在当时的洛杉矶，我想你能理解这种逻辑，因为他们坐在那里，
they're saying, we are struggling to create as much parking as possible both on the part of the city government which is building public parking like the massive Pershing Square parking garage and also the private you know entrepreneurs and department store owners themselves who are saying our survival depends upon finding parking. Well this rule made a lot of sense for a city without mass public transportation. It also had some gnarly consequences. Suddenly, lots of apartment buildings in the city weren't compliant with parking regulations,
他们说，我们正在努力创造尽可能多的停车位，一方面是市政府在建设公共停车场，比如巨大的潘兴广场停车场，另一方面是私人企业家和百货公司老板自己，他们说我们的生存取决于寻找停车位。好吧，对于一个没有公共交通系统的城市来说，这条规则很有道理。它也带来了一些棘手的后果。突然之间，城市里的许多公寓楼都不符合停车法规，
which was bad news for one of the city's most popular building types, the bungalow court. The classic wonderful Southern California typology. If you think it's either like two rows of either detached or attached like small homes on the sides of a long lot? The bungalow court is a lovely housing type. It was seen as a way for less affluent Angelenos to have a house and a shared private garden, but the courtyard created an issue. There was no space for the new mandatory parking. The bungalow courts weren't alone. If developers weren't to build a two or three-story brick
这对于该市最受欢迎的建筑类型之一——平房庭院（bungalow court）来说是个坏消息。经典而美妙的南加州建筑类型。如果你认为它就像是长形地块两侧两排独立或连体的小住宅？平房庭院是一种可爱的住房类型。它被视为不太富裕的洛杉矶人拥有房屋和共享私人花园的一种方式，但庭院带来了一个问题。没有空间留给新的强制停车位。平房庭院并不孤单。如果开发商想要建造两层或三层砖砌公寓楼，
apartment building, they needed to buy the lot next door too, just for the parking. People in LA saw the negative consequences of parking minimums pretty much right away. Like, even in the early 30s, the LA Times published article that the parking requirements essentially made it so no multi-story masonry buildings were being built anymore in LA.
他们还需要买下隔壁的地块，仅仅是为了停车。洛杉矶人几乎立刻就看到了最低停车位带来的负面后果。比如，早在 30 年代初，《洛杉矶时报》就发表了一篇文章，称停车要求基本上导致洛杉矶不再建造多层砖石建筑。
So very early on, you can see the consequences. But Los Angeles didn't back off their parking laws. In fact, they were expanded in the 1940s because city leaders were facing a looming threat from the suburbs. Well, so like most American cities in the 1940s, 50s and 60s, LA was subject to what planners at the time called decentralization, which is to say that there were all these booming suburbs on the outskirts
所以很早就你能看到后果。但洛杉矶并没有放弃他们的停车法。事实上，它们在 20 世纪 40 年代得到了扩展，因为城市领导人面临来自郊区的迫在眉睫的威胁。嗯，就像 40 年代、50 年代和 60 年代的绝大多数美国城市一样，洛杉矶受到了当时规划者称之为“去中心化”的影响，也就是说，在城市边缘有所有这些蓬勃发展的郊区。
of the city that offered residents from returning GI's coming back from more, or really anyone else who was white and was able to get a mortgage, the opportunity to go by a single family home with a front yard and a two car garage and another couple parking spots on the curb in front of the house. And that was a very seductive vision for many Americans in the 1940s, 50s and 60s. Downtown obviously was threatened by people moving out to the suburbs and they wondered, what can we do to stop ourselves from losing our population and our tax base
这些郊区为从战场返回的退伍军人，或者任何白人且能够获得抵押贷款的人，提供了购买单户住宅的机会，住宅带前院、两车位车库以及房子前面路边的另外几个停车位。对于 20 世纪 40 年代、50 年代和 60 年代的许多美国人来说，这是一个非常具有诱惑力的愿景。市中心显然受到人们搬到郊区的威胁，他们想知道，我们能做些什么来阻止我们的人口、税基和工作岗位流失到这些新的郊区社区？
and our jobs to these new suburban communities? If the city wanted to compete with the growing suburbs, they needed to fight back against one of the biggest draws of suburban living, lots and lots of free parking. Soon, the city's zoning rules included parking minimums for all types of housing, and then it was expanded to businesses. So everyone could have cheap and available street parking when shopping for shoes or getting a meal downtown.
如果这座城市想要与不断发展的郊区竞争，他们就需要反击郊区生活的一大吸引力——大量免费停车位。很快，城市的区划规则将所有类型住房都纳入了最低停车位要求，随后又扩大到了企业。因此，当人们在市中心买鞋或吃饭时，每个人都可以拥有便宜且随手可得的街边停车位。
The city's post where 1946's Zoning Code said, now it's extending to everything. Industrial buildings, commercial buildings, single-family apartments. By the 1950s, downtown Los Angeles was an aparque spiral. The city required more and more parking, which actually incentivized more and more driving, which created a need for even more parking, and things got out of hand from there. So over the years, as the parking problem in LA gets worse, they start ramping up the parking requirement. At first, it's half a parking spot with every unit. Then it's one with every unit.
该市 1946 年后的分区法规规定，现在它将扩展到一切。工业建筑、商业建筑、独栋公寓。到了 20 世纪 50 年代，洛杉矶市中心陷入了停车螺旋。城市对停车位的需求不断增加，这实际上刺激了更多的驾驶需求，从而产生了对更多停车位甚至更大的需求，事情从那时起开始失控。因此，多年来，随着洛杉矶停车问题的恶化，他们开始加大停车要求。起初，每个单元半个停车位。然后每个单元一个。
Then it's two with every unit, and so on. And you can actually watch developers respond to this and the kind of dominant form of, you know, your everyday residential architecture in Los Angeles evolves. Face with higher parking requirements, builders in LA had to get creative, which led to one of LA's most iconic housing styles.
然后每个单元两个，依此类推。你实际上可以看着开发商对此做出反应，洛杉矶日常住宅建筑的主导形式也在不断演变。面对更高的停车要求，洛杉矶的建筑商不得不发挥创造力，这催生了洛杉矶最具标志性的住宅风格之一。
The dingbat. You probably heard us talk about dingbats on the show because dingbats are pretty fun, and the word dingbat is really fun to say. They have two things a character kind of stuff them apart. One is the front is often kind of very highly decorated. The rest of it's very plain stucco, but the front often had like a atomic style, like, you know, starbursts and really cool tiling. The other distinctive thing about dingbats was tuck under parking. Every dingbatt apartment was can't a levered over a driveway, so cars could be parked
丁巴特公寓（dingbat）。你可能听我们在节目中讨论过丁巴特公寓，因为丁巴特公寓非常有趣，而且“dingbat”这个词念起来也很有趣。它们有两个特点让它们与众不同。一个是正面通常装饰非常华丽。其余部分是非常简单的灰泥，但正面通常有原子风格，比如，你知道的，星爆和非常酷的瓷砖。丁巴特公寓的另一个独特之处是隐藏式停车。每间丁巴特公寓都悬挑在车道上方，因此汽车可以停在建筑物本身的下方。
underneath the building itself. Not everybody loved them, in part because the underground parking took away a lot of sidewalk space. But for most residents, dingbats were considered a stylish way to conform with L.A.'s parking requirements. This was pretty much the most parking-centric housing you could design. And yet, in 1965, the parking minimums went up again. Most units of housing required two units of parking, and even dingbats became obsolete. Yeah, even the dingbat you couldn't build anymore. And it's true, and you see the dingbat you think, wow, this is the form that has been
并不是所有人都喜欢它们，部分原因是地下停车占用了大量的人行道空间。但对大多数居民来说，丁巴特公寓被认为是符合洛杉矶停车要求的时尚方式。这几乎是你能设计的以停车为中心的住房。然而，在 1965 年，最低停车位标准再次上调。大多数住宅单元都需要两个停车位，甚至丁巴特公寓也过时了。是的，连丁巴特公寓你都不能再建了。确实如此，当你看到丁巴特公寓时，你会想，哇，这是一种绝对为依赖汽车的社会而开发的建筑形式。
developed for a society that's dependent on the automobile for sure. Eventually, every small and medium residential building type became impossible to construct in downtown Los Angeles. The parking minimums created yet another type of housing architecture in the city. Many new apartment towers had several story parking garages at the base and the apartments above were shaped by the needs of the garage below. Yeah, I talked to some architects who were saying
最终，洛杉矶市中心的所有中小型住宅建筑都变得无法建造。最低停车位催生了该市另一种住房建筑类型。许多新的公寓楼底部都有几层停车场，上面的公寓则根据下方停车场的需要而塑造。是的，我和一些建筑师交流过，他们说
that the first thing you need to figure out is how many parking spaces you can get in there. You need to maximize your number of parking spaces so that you can maximize your number of units above. And to maximize that, you require placing these pillars at certain places in the parking garage, right? And then that's the form of your building. It's been determined by the placement
你需要弄清楚的第一件事是你能把多少停车位塞进去。你需要最大化你的停车位数量，以便最大化上面单元的数量。为了最大化这一点，你需要在停车场内的特定位置放置这些柱子，对吧？然后这就是你建筑的形状。它是由停车场那些柱子的位置决定的。因此，这最终塑造了上面单元的设计。这有点像是停车如何驱动社会中其他事物设计的一个绝妙寓意。
of those pillars in the parking garage. And so that ends up shaping the design of the units above. And it's sort of, it's a neat allegory for how parking drives the design of other things in society. By the turn of the 21st century, it's a neat allegory for how parking drives the design of other things in society. By the turn of the 21st century, there was a boom in these mishapen apartment towers with massive parking garages at the bottom, because the parking math was so complicated for smaller building types. So if you're building a condo, for example, in Los Angeles in the 1990s. You need to include 2.25 to 2.5 covered on-site parking spaces for every unit.
到了 21 世纪之交，这种底部有巨大停车场、形状畸形的公寓楼迎来了繁荣，因为较小建筑类型的停车计算过于复杂。因此，如果你在 1990 年代的洛杉矶建造公寓，你需要为每个单元提供 2.25 到 2.5 个带顶棚的现场停车位。
So let's do the math on this Roman. You're a developer in a Los Angeles neighborhood and you have a small parcel you inherited from your grandfather and it's a blank lot and you'd like to put some housing on this lot, help to solve your city's housing crisis. If you wanna build five units, you are required to include five times 2.5, 12.5, and then round up 13 parking spaces. 13 parking spaces on an infill lot,
所以我们来算算这笔账，罗曼。你是一个洛杉矶社区的开发商，你有一小块从你祖父那里继承下来的空地，这是一块毛坯地，你想在这块地上建一些住房，帮助解决你城市的住房危机。如果你想建五套房，你必须包括 5 乘以 2.5，即 12.5，然后四舍五入到 13 个停车位。在填充地块上有 13 个停车位，
you can't fit those on the ground floor. So now you're talking about a two-story garage, or potentially an extremely expensive underground excavation, just to put five condos on this lot. And five is not a large number, that's the size of your average sort of infill brownstone on the Upper West side. And suddenly that kind of construction becomes completely impossible. Because of both the geometry of putting those parking spaces on the small lot, and both the geometry of putting those parking spaces on the small lot and also the cost because building parking is very expensive.
你没法把它们塞进底层。所以现在你在谈论一个两层楼的车库，或者可能是一个极其昂贵的地下挖掘，只为了在这块地上建五套公寓。而“五”并不是一个很大的数字，这相当于上西区普通填充褐石建筑的规模。突然之间，这种建设变得完全不可能。因为在小地块上放置这些停车位的几何学问题，以及由于建造停车位非常昂贵而带来的成本问题。
But Lausy new buildings weren't the only consequence of parking requirements. Most of LA's old buildings couldn't be converted into something new. There are some historic structures here that many people drive by and they say, gosh, that would be just perfect for a little restaurant or a little coffee shop or what have you.
但洛杉矶的新建筑并不是停车要求的唯一后果。洛杉矶的大多数旧建筑都无法改造成新东西。这里有一些历史建筑，许多人开车路过时会说，天哪，这简直太适合开个小餐馆或小咖啡馆之类的了。
And then they realize that building was built before 1950. It has no parking or it has two or three parking spaces. And so there's a padlock around it, a metaphorical padlock. But to some extent, it, you know, renovating it and turning it into a new thing would require demolishing something adjacent in order to provide the parking. Mark Vallionato says all this parking in LA is a big contributor to the city's housing crisis. Because of parking minimums,
然后他们意识到那栋建筑是 1950 年之前建造的。它没有停车位，或者只有两三个停车位。因此周围挂着一把锁，一把隐喻的锁。但在某种程度上，你知道，翻新并将其变成新东西需要拆除相邻的建筑来提供停车位。马克·瓦利奥纳托斯表示，洛杉矶的所有这些停车位是导致该市住房危机的一大因素。由于最低停车位标准，
new housing is very difficult to build, and many places that could be turned in the housing are set aside for parking lots. And the ultimate result to that is essentially we have 40,000 people homeless, right? So in the streets of Los Angeles, because you made it impossible to provide homes for people again because we're prioritizing space for automobiles. Parking minimums have led to all these problems that are really hard to unwind.
新住房很难建造，许多本可以变成住房的地方都被划为停车场。其最终结果基本上是我们有 40,000 名无家可归的人，对吧？所以在洛杉矶的街头，因为你让人类无法再次获得家园，因为我们把汽车空间放在了首位。最低停车位导致了所有这些极难解决的问题。
In an LA, it can feel hard to eliminate parking since the city doesn't offer many alternatives to driving. But recently, LA has taken steps to fight back against its parking culture. In 1999, the city passed an adaptive reuse ordinance, or ARO. The law made it easier for developers to convert old office buildings into housing to get more people living downtown. Developers didn't want to buy these buildings since they had the dreaded parking padlock on them. So to make conversions more enticing for developers, the city did something kind of radical. It waived parking minimums for these conversion projects.
在洛杉矶，由于这座城市没有提供太多除了开车之外的替代选择，消除停车位会让人感觉很困难。但最近，洛杉矶采取了措施来反击其停车文化。1999 年，该市通过了一项自适应再利用条例（ARO）。该法律使开发商更容易将旧办公楼改造成住宅，以吸引更多人居住在市中心。开发商不想买这些建筑，因为它们带有可怕的停车锁。因此，为了让改造对开发商更有吸引力，该市采取了一项颇为激进的举措。它豁免了这些改造项目的最低停车位要求。
Right. So basically, you have these developers who start snatching up these buildings. And these buildings are, at this point, all but worthless. I mean, we're talking about like people buying 12 store buildings for hundreds of thousands of dollars, right? They're super cheap because they have the parking padlock on the front door. Just say like, they're empty and you can't do anything with them. You can't turn them into something new because they don't have enough parking.
没错。所以基本上，你有了这些开始抢购这些建筑的开发商。此时这些建筑几乎一文不值。我的意思是，我们讨论的是人们以数十万美元的价格买下 12 层的建筑，对吧？它们超级便宜，因为它们的前门上挂着停车锁。就像，它们是空的，你什么也做不了。你不能把它们变成新东西，因为它们没有足够的停车位。
And so once the city gets rid of this obligation, developers start buying them and they start turning them into new residential units just about immediately. So according to the landmark study of the ARO by a planning professor named Michael Manville who's at UCLA, he went and interviewed all these developers. And he found that between 1999 and 2008, this is basically 10-year period. Developers use this ordinance to create 6,900 units in downtown LA. So almost 7,000 new apartments were built at this time.
因此，一旦市里取消了这个义务，开发商就开始购买它们，并几乎立即开始将它们改造成新的住宅单元。因此，根据加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的一位名叫迈克尔·曼维尔（Michael Manville）的规划教授对 ARO 的标志性研究，他去采访了所有这些开发商。他发现，在 1999 年到 2008 年之间，这基本上是一个 10 年的时期。开发商利用这项条例在洛杉矶市中心创造了 6,900 个单元。因此，当时建造了将近 7,000 套新公寓。
And the craziest thing is that the ARRO created more housing in those 10 years than had been built period in the previous 30. I think that's part of what you feel in downtown LA is like a sense that it's a real neighborhood now. It's not just an office district that closes at 5 p.m. 7,000 new housing units is impressive, but it's only a drop in the bucket. A lot more has to be done.
最疯狂的是，ARO 在这 10 年里创造的住房比过去 30 年里建造的总和还要多。我认为这就是你在洛杉矶市中心感受到的部分原因，就像这里现在是一个真正的社区一样。它不仅仅是一个下午 5 点就关门的办公区。7,000 套新住宅令人印象深刻，但这只是杯水车薪。还有很多工作要做。
Recently, the state of California passed a law saying housing within a half mile of major public transit stops will not require parking on site. And this year, Los Angeles City Council is poised to change everything. In early May, City Council passed new zoning plans for downtown Los Angeles and Hollywood. The plans are designed to encourage more housing
最近，加利福尼亚州通过了一项法律，规定主要公共交通站点半英里范围内的住房将不需要现场停车。今年，洛杉矶市议会准备改变一切。5 月初，市议会通过了针对洛杉矶市中心和好莱坞的新分区规划。这些规划旨在鼓励更多的住房，
and they include the elimination of parking minimums for all new residential developments. There has been some pushback from residents who worry about losing their parking spaces, but many urbanists are excited by the changes. It feels like we are in the final days of minimum parking requirements, because LA isn't the only city going down this path. San Jose, Seattle, Portland, Austin, Texas, like it's all over the place. It heralds exciting things for the future of what's gonna happen with parking and architecture,
并且它们包括取消所有新住宅开发的最低停车位要求。一些担心失去停车位的居民对此进行了一些回击，但许多城市规划者对这些变化感到兴奋。感觉我们正处于最低停车位要求的最后几天，因为洛杉矶不是唯一走这条路的城市。圣何塞、西雅图、波特兰、德克萨斯州奥斯汀，到处都是。它预示着停车和建筑未来的激动人心的事情，
or at least a more flexible world in which people who want to, for example, create low-income housing with no parking spots are able to do so. I think it does take some adjustment, but at the end of the day, I think people do recognize ultimately that housing for people is more important than parking for cars. The
或者至少是一个更灵活的世界，想要创建没有停车位的低收入住房的人能够做到这一点。我认为这确实需要一些调整，但归根结底，我认为人们最终认识到，为人提供住房比为车提供停车位更重要。
Coming up, the incredible tale of how selling Chicago's parking meters became a political blunder for the history books. After this. So we're back with Henry Gabbard. Congratulations on the book. It is so good. I loved reading it. It's easy breezy.
接下来的节目中，将讲述出售芝加哥停车计时器如何成为载入史册的政治大失误的故事。广告之后见。我们回来了，嘉宾是亨利·加巴德。祝贺你出书。这本书太棒了。我读得很开心。轻松轻快。
It has some stuff I know, some stuff it was brand new to me. Why did you decide to focus on parking for the last two, five, six, seven years of your life? Because I just love it so much, Roman. I can't get enough of it. No, but the truth is that I'm a journalist. I write about cities, and so I write about urban subjects, like housing and transportation, and flooding,
里面有一些我知道的东西，也有一些对我来说全新的东西。为什么你决定把过去两、五、六年甚至七年的生命聚焦在停车上？因为我太爱它了，罗曼。我怎么都看不够。不，但事实是，我是一名记者。我写关于城市的内容，所以我写城市主题，比如住房和交通、洪水、
and infrastructure, and in subject after subject and in story after story, this thing kept coming up. And this thing was this vast system of parking that we've established, but that no one really understands, and that exerts all these hidden consequences on the way that all these other city systems work. It can be something as basic as like, why do we not have bus-rappered transit?
基础设施，在接下来的每一个主题和一个又一个的故事中，这件事一直出现。而这件事就是我们建立的这个庞大的停车系统，但没有人真正理解它，它对所有这些其他城市系统的运作方式产生了所有这些隐藏的影响。这可能是非常基础的事情，比如为什么我们没有公交专用道？
Like why do buses get stuck in traffic and they have to run behind all these cars? And the answer is often just because the city is unwilling to mess with the street parking, right? I also just think it's interesting. I mean, I know there's like a joke that like a parking that's so boring. And I've definitely heard people say like, oh, wow, parking. Fun. But then you get them talking about it.
比如为什么公交车会陷入交通堵塞，它们不得不跟在所有这些汽车后面？答案往往只是因为这座城市不愿意搞乱路边停车，对吧？我也只是觉得这很有趣。我的意思是，我知道有个笑话叫停车太无聊了。我绝对听人说过，哦，哇，停车。真有意思。但当你让他们谈论它时，
And it turns out that like everybody's gotten opinion. So when it stories in your book that I knew a little bit about, but I didn't know the full story of until I read it, is the debacle of the privatization of parking meters in Chicago. So could you just tell me that story and how that all got started? Yeah, so when I was writing this book, I was living in Chicago, and as anybody who lives in Chicago knows, Chicago has pretty high parking meter rates on some of its busy commercial corridors. And the reason that Chicago has such high parking meter rates on some of its busy commercial corridors. And the reason that Chicago has the Thai parking meter rates on its busy commercial corridors
事实证明每个人都有看法。所以你书中的一个故事我略知一二，但在阅读之前我并不知道完整的故事，那就是芝加哥私有化停车计时器的惨败。所以你能给我讲讲那个故事以及这一切是如何开始的吗？是的，当我写这本书时，我住在芝加哥，正如任何住在芝加哥的人都知道的那样，芝加哥在其一些繁忙的商业走廊上有相当高的停车计时器费率。芝加哥在其一些繁忙的商业走廊上有如此高的停车计时器费率的原因。芝加哥在其繁忙的商业走廊上有泰国的停车计时器费率的原因
is because all the parking meters in the city were released to a group of Wall Street investors in 2008. And so Chicago's parking meters are now run basically by Wall Street. And as a result, they're really expensive and they make people really mad all the time. And as we're still they're really expensive and they make people really mad all the time. So how did that happen? How did this sort of public resource where the city makes a good kind of living, a one-quarter at a time through targeting for parking and probably not targeting enough became something that Morgan Stanley owned and monopolizes. Yeah.
是因为该市所有的停车计时器在 2008 年都被租给了一群华尔街投资者。所以芝加哥的停车计时器现在基本上由华尔街运营。结果，它们非常昂贵，总是让人们非常生气。更糟的是，它们非常昂贵，总是让人们非常生气。这怎么发生的？这种公共资源，城市通过每次投币寻找停车位（可能针对性还不够）过着不错的生活，怎么就成了摩根士丹利拥有并垄断的东西了呢？是的。
So in 2008, the mayor of Chicago, Richard M. Daily, is obsessed with selling off some of the city's public resources. And he's got this idea that the future of municipal government is in finding private operators who will pay the city for the privilege of running these public services and do it better than the city used to do it, and the city will get more money and everybody wins. And 2008, the recession is bearing down the stock market is tanking. Everybody's starting to panic about the municipal budget and daily gets this offer from Morgan Stanley. And Morgan Stanley wants to rent Chicago's parking meters, all 36,000 parking meters for
所以在 2008 年，芝加哥市长理查德·M·戴利痴迷于出售该市的一些公共资源。他有一个想法，即市政政府的未来在于寻找私人运营商，他们将向城市支付费用以换取运营这些公共服务的特权，并且比城市过去做得更好，城市将获得更多的钱，每个人都赢了。2008 年，经济衰退逼近，股市暴跌。每个人都开始对市政预算感到恐慌，戴利收到了摩根士丹利的这份报价。摩根士丹利想租下芝加哥的停车计时器，全部 36,000 个停车计时器，
the next 75 years. And the bank is going to offer Chicago a flat payment of $1.1 billion. And I think daily looks at that, and he says, wow, dollar signs light up in his eyes, and he says, a billion dollars, are you giving me, yes. It's Chicago, right? Like the mayor says he's got this great deal. The city council basically gets brow beaten
租期 75 年。这家银行将向芝加哥提供 11 亿美元的一次性付款。我想戴利看了看，然后他说，哇，美元符号在他的眼中亮起，他说，十亿美元，你给我，是的。这里是芝加哥，对吧？市长说他得到了这笔划算的交易。市议会基本上被胁迫
into accepting it without even reading the contract. And by 2009, Chicago has sold all of its parking meters away for the next 75 years. So are Chicago parking meters really that valuable? Because for a long time, they were very affordable. Like why did the city keep them so low? I think part of the problem is that raising parking meter rates is very unpopular. And so Chicago was not alone in that it had basically neglected to raise parking meter rates for decades,
在甚至没有阅读合同的情况下接受了它。到 2009 年，芝加哥已经将未来 75 年的所有停车计时器都卖掉了。那么芝加哥的停车计时器真的那么有价值吗？因为很长一段时间里，它们非常实惠。为什么城市把价格保持得这么低？我认为部分问题在于提高停车计时器费率非常不受欢迎。因此芝加哥并不孤孤单单，几十年来它基本上忽略了提高停车计时器费率，
to the extent that they cease to be useful as a way of actually managing street space, which is the kind of original purpose of the parking meter. Listen, sidebar, the original purpose of the parking meter is not to ring money out of taxpayers, right? You can just raise taxes if that's what you want to do. The point of the parking meter is to manage this scarce resource we have, which is like the curb, the vital access point to all the property on a busy street. And the parking meter is a way to manage that. It's a way
以至于它们不再用作实际管理街道空间的有效方式，而这正是停车计时器的初衷。听着，顺便说一句，停车计时器的初衷不是为了榨取纳税人的钱，对吧？如果你想这样做，你可以直接加税。停车计时器的目的是管理我们拥有的这种稀缺资源，比如路缘，这是繁忙街道上所有财产的重要接入点。停车计时器是管理这一资源的一种方式。这是一种
to make sure that that's not monopolized all day by somebody who's just leaving their car there for a day at a time. And in Chicago, the parking meter had long ceased to have this function, right? They'd gotten super cheap. They hadn't raised the rates in decades. And in fact, they were collecting somewhere between five and ten times more in parking tickets than they were from the actual meters themselves. And that's actually typical of most American cities.
确保它不会被整天把车停在那里的某个人垄断的方式。在芝加哥，停车计时器早已失去这一功能，对吧？它们变得超级便宜。几十年来他们没有提高费率。事实上，他们从停车罚单中收取的费用是实际计时器本身收集的 5 到 10 倍。这实际上是大多数美国城市的典型特征。
There's more money comes from parking punishment than from actually the parking meters themselves. And that to me seems like a system that's very poorly designed and working backwards. When the time came and they received this offer for the parking meters, I don't think anybody really had a sense of how high the price could go.
惩罚停车带来的钱比实际停车计时器本身的钱还要多。对我来说，这似乎是一个设计非常糟糕且本末倒置的系统。当时机到来并且他们收到停车计时器的报价时，我认为没有人真正知道价格能涨多高。
Now of course, that was implicit in Morgan Stanley's offer, right? Like there was no mystery how they were gonna crunch a billion dollars out of these parking meters. Obviously they were going to raise the parking meter rates, but the city argued that politically speaking, they didn't have the political capacity to raise that money themselves.
当然，这隐含在摩根士丹利的报价中，对吧？从这些停车计时器中榨取 10 亿美元毫无神秘感。显然他们会提高停车计时器的费率，但市政府辩称，从政治上讲，他们没有政治能力自己筹集这笔资金。
It could only happen if they relinquished control to this group of private investors for 75 years. That's the only way those parking meter rates could get that high. How bad of a deal was this and how quickly did people figure it out? It became apparent pretty quickly that this was a bad deal. In 2009, six months after this deal gets signed, the Inspector General of Chicago Drops report, the Inspector General, this guy's name is David Hoffman, and Hoffman finds that
只有把控制权让给这群私人投资者 75 年，这种情况才会发生。这是停车计时器费率变得那么高的唯一途径。这笔交易有多糟糕，人们花了多长时间才发现？这笔交易很糟糕，这一点很快就变得显而易见。2009 年，这笔交易签署六个月后，芝加哥总监察长发布了一份报告，总监察长，这家伙叫大卫·霍夫曼，霍夫曼发现
the parking meters were worth between two and three and a half billion dollars. And remember Chicago got and paid one billion dollars for them. So basically, they had left a billion dollars on the table at minimum. And it's not surprising because it was a very opaque bidding process. Like, yes, they tested the market and they found the best buyer they could, but there were only a couple of bitters and no surprise because like, how robust is the market and they found the best buyer they could, but there were only a couple of bitters and no surprise because like how robust is the market for like a 75-year lease of 36,000 parking meters? It's not like buying a gallon of milk, right?
这些停车计时器的价值在 20 到 35 亿美元之间。请记住，芝加哥为它们获得并支付了 10 亿美元。所以基本上，他们至少在桌面上留下了 10 亿美元。这并不奇怪，因为这是一个非常不透明的投标过程。是的，他们测试了市场并找到了他们能找到的最佳买家，但只有几个竞标者，这并不奇怪，因为针对 75 年期 36,000 个停车计时器的租赁市场有多健全？这不像买加仑牛奶，对吧？
It's very untested. And so not surprisingly, Chicago worked really fast and they wound up with a very, very bad deal. And even worse than it appears, right? Because not only did they realize pretty soon after, like, wow, if we had raised our parking meter rates, we could have made this money for the city. And in fact, the investors who bought the parking meters
这是非常未经测试的。因此不出意料，芝加哥动作非常快，最终得到了一笔非常非常糟糕的交易。甚至比看起来更糟，对吧？因为不仅在此之后不久他们就意识到，哇，如果我们提高了停车计时器的费率，我们本可以为这座城市赚到这笔钱，事实上，买下停车计时器的投资者
have since made their money back. And this is, we are what, like, 15 years later now. There are 60 years left on the deal, and they have already made all their money back. Insult to injury, right? Not only were the parking meters more expensive, but instead of this revenue being used to fund city improvements, clean the streets, build public infrastructure, plant trees, pay for schools, whatever, all this money was going to Wall Street investors.
从那以后已经把钱赚回来了。而现在，我们距离当时大约过去了 15 年。这笔交易还有 60 年到期，他们已经把所有的钱都赚回来了。雪上加霜，对吧？不仅停车计时器更贵了，而且这些收入没有被用来资助城市改善、清理街道、建设公共基础设施、种植树木、支付学校费用等，所有的钱都流向了华尔街投资者。
And that I think is very painful every time you pay for parking on a Chicago street. You just feel like you're throwing money down the drain. And that's annoying. And then the other thing about it that became apparent in the years afterwards was they hadn't just sold the parking meters, but because the parking meters are tied to the use of that street as parking, you couldn't change the function of the streets.
我认为，每次你在芝加哥街道上支付停车费时，都会感到非常痛苦。你只觉得自己是在把钱扔进下水道。这很烦人。随后的几年里变得明显的另一件事是，他们不仅卖掉了停车计时器，而且因为停车计时器与该街道作为停车场的用途挂钩，你无法改变街道的功能。
And so if you wanted to build a back lane, or a bus lane, it was gonna take away hundreds of street parking spots. You had to find a back land or a bus land, it was going to take away hundreds of street parking spots. You had to find a way to compensate Morgan Stanley for all those disappeared parking spots. You know, put meters in somewhere else and the meters there somewhere else had to be just as good as the meters that went away. And Chicago found itself in all this hot water.
因此，如果你想建造后巷或公交专用道，它会夺走数百个路街停车位。你必须找到后巷或公交专用道，它会夺走数百个路街停车位。你必须想办法补偿摩根士丹利所有这些消失的停车位。你知道，在其他地方安装计时器，其他地方的计时器必须和消失的计时器一样好。芝加哥发现自己陷入了所有这些水深火热之中。
We're pretty soon they were paying Morgan Stanley money. And so Morgan Stanley started charging Chicago. And Chicago was forking over tens of millions of dollars every year to this company for problems with the meters. Every time they wanted to hold a ticker tape parade, you know, if the Cubs won the World Series, every time they wanna have a farmer's market or close the street, I mean, this becomes like
很快他们就在向摩根士丹利支付金钱。所以摩根士丹利开始向芝加哥收费。为了计时器的问题，芝加哥每年都要向这家公司上交数千万美元。每当他们想举行纸带游行（如果小熊队赢得世界大赛），每当他们想举办农贸市场或封锁街道时，我的意思是，这成为了
a major drag on the types of things that the city is able to do. And continues to be so. And I think as Chicago begins to think about how they're gonna provide electric vehicle charging at the curb, I think as Chicago begins to think about how they're going to provide electric vehicle charging at the curb, I think it's going to be a real problem for them that they do not have control over 36,000 of their best curb parking spaces. Wow. Well, Henry, the book is so good and I enjoy talking with you and I know people listen to show, but I just love the hell out of it. So thank you so much. I appreciate it. Thanks for having me, Roland.
城市能够做的事情的主要拖累。并且现在依然如此。而且我认为，当芝加哥开始考虑如何在路边提供电动汽车充电时，我认为，当芝加哥开始考虑如何在路边提供电动汽车充电时，他们无法控制自己 30,000 多个最好的路边停车位，这将成为他们真正的问题。哇。好吧，亨利，这本书太棒了，我很享受与你交谈，我知道人们听节目，但我太喜欢它了。非常感谢。我很感激。谢谢你邀请我，罗曼。
Henry Gabbard's book is called Paved Paradise, How Parking Explains the World. You can find it in bookstores right now. 99% invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, original music by Swan Rial, sound mixed by Martin Gonzales. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director. The Rosa team includes Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Loshamadon, Jacob Moltenotta Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe
亨利·加巴德的书名为《铺就的天堂：停车如何解释世界》。你现在可以在书店里找到它。本周的 99% Invisible 由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，原创音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作，声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。制作团队包括杰森·德·莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、维维安·李、洛沙·马顿、雅各布·莫尔蒂诺塔·梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森博格和我有罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作，本周特别感谢卡罗尔·沙茨。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北方六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。位于美丽。奥克兰上城，加利福尼亚州。
Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence, special thanks this week to Carol Shatz. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @ 我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI org）。我们也在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。